well Adrian Pelosi is starting this
conference by talking about the order of
business which we have before us today
on the House floor which is debate and
voting on this War Powers Resolution
this is a democratic resolution that
Pelosi laid out which is in response to
what she called and she repeated these
comments just now again what she calls
the disproportionate and provocative
actions of President Trump when he
ordered the drone strike that killed
soleimani now this resolution seeks to
end US military hostilities toward Iran
within 30 days unless Trump goes back to
Congress and receives congressional
approval of course Democrats are citing
the US Constitution that says the power
to make war is one that is shared
equally between the two branches the
executive and the legislative well the
debate hasn't quite started on this
measure it is expected in the coming
hour or so and then a vote by the end of
the day here in Washington and because
the house is controlled by Democrats
this war war powers resolution is
expected to pass now the Senate is
looking at a very similar measure
they're not officially debating it yet
but we also heard statements from
senators today and yesterday regarding
that and what's notable Adrienne is that
there were at least two senators
yesterday who were saying these are
Republican senators who said that they
would support this Senate War Powers
Resolution they came to that conclusion
after getting the intelligence briefing
on what Trump's intelligence was before
he made that call to kill general
Soleimani and those two Republican
senators said that they were insulted by
the briefing because it offered so
little information and did not allow
them to debate they said that was the
executive branch super over taking too
much of the pie really cutting trying to
cut out Congress in enacting its due
power which is the co-equal power of
Congress to make
or and so we know that at least two
Republican senators have said they would
support this resolution that really
would handcuff the president going
forward to limiting these military
aggressions against Iran to thirty days
unless Congress says otherwise how do
you many thanks indeed Heidi's your
caster on Capitol Hill not so far away
is our White House correspondent
Kimberly how could is with us now what
does the president think of these
efforts to curb his War Powers Kimberly
he doesn't like it very much and he's
letting us know about it on Twitter the
u.s. president pushing back on that
debate taking place in the House of
Representatives to limit his ability to
respond militarily to any sort of threat
from Iran or if for him to act
unilaterally without congressional
approval here's what he writes hope that
all House Republicans will vote against
crazy Nancy Pelosi's War Powers
Resolution also remember her speed and
rush and getting the impeachment hoax
voted on and done well she never said
the articles to the Senate just another
Democrat fraud presidential harassment
it's not presidential harassment it's
constitutionally mandated particularly
when it comes to the discussion of war
it must be debated it must be something
that this is discussed and approved by
Congress so the US president couldn't
push back but the reality is that this
is a law and he has no more power than
the US Congress he's not the only one
pushing back his vice president is doing
it too yeah and how did Joe Castro
mentioned there there have been
briefings that have been taking place on
Capitol Hill and it's not just Democrats
that don't like those briefings that
have been coming from the president's
top security advisors it's also some
members of his own Republican Party they
feel a couple of things haven't happened
they haven't justified that strike on
general Soleimani they also say that
this assassination in no way was
imminent at least they haven't seen the
evidence of that vice president Mike
Pence is saying yeah we can't show you
the evidence but you're gonna have to
trust us if we were to share all of the
intelligence and in fact some of the
most
telling evidence that that Qasem
Soleimani was preparing an eminent
attack against American forces an
American personnel also represents some
of the most sensitive intelligence that
we have it could compromise those
sources and methods so look respect I
have tremendous respect for Senator Mike
Lee I recognize he's had a difference of
opinion with our administration over
self-defense measures the president
authorized in Yemen but look will will
welcome those debates going forward but
I can assure your viewers that those of
us that that have seen all the evidence
that saw the evidence in real time know
that President Trump made the right
decision to take Qasem Soleimani off the
battlefield America is safer the world
is safer unfortunately those assurances
aren't sitting well with many members of
Congress because the fact is that many
remember a generation ago when similar
arguments were made about the threat of
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq
using intelligence that couldn't be
shared
well that invasion took place only later
for Americans to find out that
intelligence was in fact flawed a White
House correspondent Kimberly halket
reporting live there from Washington
Kimberly many thanks indeed to Joseph
who is an associate professor of
political science at Texas A&M
University in cat-eyes with me here in
the studio what do you make of that
language by the president their
presidential harassment he's calling it
well president Trump makes a habit of
maximizing sort of the scope of domestic
harm a political conflict of sort of
exaggerating the degree to which normal
political debate between Republicans and
Democrats sort of a unique attack
against him to be presidents of both
parties in fact Congress pushed back on
their decisions as commander in chief
and and what you know is sort of a
normal domestic debate about a military
action of course the the president casts
in these extreme terms he must be aware
that that you know as far as the
executive branches of power are
concerned he's equal to it to Congress
here again president Trump has sort of
shown
again that may be the the intricacies of
the constitutional system are not
especially important to him and and I
think just as a matter of his rhetoric
he is is apt to say that he has
unilateral authority when in fact that
constitutional system gives Congress a
role to to constrain the president so
what if Congress does
as expected vote to constrain the
president today what happens then well
the of course the measure we need to go
to the Senate and pass there where the
Republicans hold a majority I've heard
news that Senator Paul from Kentucky
senator Lee from Utah may join Democrats
but it remains to be seen whether a
majority can be cobbled together there
if the measure dies in the Senate then
presumably president Trump would
interpret that as having a free hand to
continue to do what he wanted in Iraq
with respect to Iran okay but but if it
does by some fluke pass is it it's
president Trump able to ignore it I mean
he will be able to veto it right as he
did with the War Powers Resolution with
respect to Yemen just this last spring
so Congress does have this Authority but
as with all things that's shared
Congress has other tools at its disposal
right they can use their power to
control the federal budget
- maybe withhold funding for war in Iran
or excuse me with Iran but you know this
is a classic case of conflict in the
separation of powers in American
government